هنا في قريه البصالح بمنطقه اليوسفيه جنوب
بغداد يقع منزل التوام السيامي عمر وعلي
اللذين اجريت لهما عمليه جراحيه استغرقت
11 ساعه حبس معها سكان القريه انفاسهم وهم
يتابعون اولا باول تفاصيل العمليه التي
اجريت في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي
للاطفال في السعوديه
فاقت الفرحه في ابناء عمومته والمنطقه وكل
الشعب العراقي فرحه ما مثلها فرحه هاي
العمليه انطتهم الحياه جديده العمر وعلي
العمليه لكن بقوا بتشهوه خلقي مدى الحياه
بس الحمد لله والشكر وفضل الله وفضل
الفريق الطبي اللي يتم هذه العمليه بنجاح
وان شاء الله صارت لهم حياه جديده
اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من بعد ولادتهما
قضاها هذا التوام السيامي هنا قبل نقلهما
الى الرياض لاجراء واحده من اكثر العمليات
تعقيدا لفصل التوائم في العالم
الطبي على مساعدتهم ان اللي هم ساهموا
باخراج
التوام
من العراق الى الرياض ونجاح هذه العمليه
بالنسبه
للطفلين السيامي علي وعمر وعادتهم الى
الحياه من جديد اجواء الفرح هنا تعم هذه
القريه التي تنتظر بفارغ الصبري عوده
التوام السيامي عمر وعلي من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بعد نجاح عمليه فصلهما
ومنحهما حياه جديده من اليوسفيه جنوب
بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه